how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we have
some really cool
one division news if you were wondering
what the first episode and actually the
first
few episodes of the wanda vision show
would be like today we're going to go
over
a major plot point that's going to take
place over the first few episodes of the
season
right now the things that we do know
about the wanna vision series are kind
of
all over the place we know that there's
going to be agatha harkness an actual
witch and there are going to be other
witches as well during the salem witch
trial because we've seen leaked photos
of these
we also know that the government and
sword are going to be involved
specifically darcy lewis from
thor and thor the dark world and jimmy
wu
from ant-man and the wasp but today's
plot point gives us a little bit of a
better idea of why all of these
different characters are involved in the
one division series
so i'll break it all down in this video
but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
recent
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
scarlet witch
funko pop all you have to do to enter
subscribe to my channel like this video
and leave a comment down below
so we already know that the one division
series is going to be kind of based off
of the house of m
we know that wanda is going to be
creating multiple realities and in these
realities she'll kind of have her
picture perfect life
vision will be there she'll be married
to him and they have kids the twins but
we know that these realities are fake
they're not
real life and that brings us into
something that was recently discovered
about the wanda vision series
charles murphy has recently reported
that he has heard from his
inside sources that the one division
series is going to be loosely based off
of the west coast
avengers currently in a collection
edition titled
vision quest now this is a very
interesting storyline and it actually
fits kind of perfectly for what's going
on
in the mcu with wanda and vision right
now so
in this comic run vision ends up going
missing and of course
wanda ends up going out to look for him
over the next handful of episodes
wanda ends up finding that he's been
taken by a multinational group called
vigilance she ends up tracking them down
and when she finds them
she finds out that they've actually
disassembled vision
he's completely deconstructed and his
parts are laying out on a table
she also finds out that his memory and
his data has been
completely wiped clean she finds out
that vision has
absolutely no recollection of his
previous life including wanda
and their life together now something
that's pretty important to note is that
when they finally put vision back
together he comes back
as an all-white version of himself and
there's actually a lot of symbolism
that goes into this look when they
reassemble vision hank pym
explains that he can recreate vision's
mind but the data is all gone and he
can't fill it with the memories of his
past
they're gone so vision is essentially a
white
blank slate an empty canvas to be filled
in so this new
all-white version of vision is
essentially a new vision
a vision with absolutely no memory of
everything that had happened in the past
now we actually do have some evidence
that we are going to be getting the
white vision many comic book fans may
have noticed a very important detail in
avengers infinity war
at the end of infinity war in wakanda
when thanos goes to retrieve the mind
stone
from vision and is successful in ripping
it out of his head
instantly killing vision when he drops
vision's body to the ground his body
essentially loses all color to it it
turns very
grayish and whitish now after many
people saw this we thought that we were
going to be getting a west coast
avengers version of vision in avengers
end game but of course he was nowhere to
be found in the movie
but we do know that he's going to be
coming back in the one division series
but there are actually two ways that
he's going to be coming back
one is in these new realities that wanda
creates where he is there
however these aren't necessarily real
versions of
vision and most people anticipate that
eventually wando will realize that these
new realities
aren't real so just like in vision quest
wanda is going to try and put vision
back together
and this is going to be a pretty major
plot of a few episodes of the one
division series
wanda seeking to bring vision back to
life but then
once she finally does he has absolutely
no memory of her or anything that has
happened over the few years
and as you can imagine this is going to
be pretty devastating to wanda we know
how much she misses
vision we know how much of a good match
they were she barely managed to kill him
when the fate of the entire universe was
at hand
so she's going to go searching for him
and try to put him back together but
it's going to be unsuccessful and this
could actually be a reason why wanda
starts to go
mad in the house of m and stories
leading up to house of m wanda kind of
starts to slowly go insane
she realizes that her sons were taken
away from her and the memory of her sons
were wiped from her
as well by agatha harkness who of course
is going to be in the series
so wanda finally finding all the parts
to vision
finally recreating him and bringing him
back and then him not remembering her or
anything
could be one of those things that kind
of pushes her over the edge
but another thing that charles murphy
also notes is that this is how shield
and sword
could be involved we've seen many leaked
pictures at this point of
a sword so we know that sword is going
to be involved but a lot of us are
questioning
why what do they have to do with wanda
essentially a witch
well based off of the leaked photos that
we've seen of wanda
outside of the sword building charles
speculates that there could be two
things happening here one is that sword
is actually helping wanda put vision
back together or two
would be that sword is actually
responsible for taking him apart
at this time there's really no way of
knowing but one thing that we can't
expect is when vision actually comes
back and the real
reality where everything is taking place
he will probably be
the white version of vision and will
most likely have no recollection of the
events of infinity war
civil war age of ultron or wanda
and further proof as charles points out
is that marvel employee
sean cindio has often posted on his
instagram teasing upcoming productions
posted
a picture of the cover of vision quest
on his
instagram seemingly teasing that we are
going to be getting
white vision again implying that he's
going to have absolutely no recollection
of
anything so a big plot of what's going
to happen in a few episodes of the wanda
vision series is wanda is going to go
out and search for
vision whether that's his body or pieces
of his body and then attempt to put him
back together and bring him back to life
only to find out that he's going to have
no memory of her
or anything that has happened over the
few years that he's been alive
so let me know what you think about this
plot point and how do you think it's
going to play into
wanda and her alternate realities of
vision being alive and her having kids
let me know what you think in the
comments down below and don't forget to
like the video and subscribe with
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on all things relating to the
marvel cinematic universe for live
updates you can follow me on twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof